and now for the moment you've been
waiting for let's hit this green run
button it will prompt us to choose a
device without a physical device we can
test the app using the emulator that
comes with Android SDK an Android
virtual device should have already been
created for you automatically when you
set up Android studio so you can go
ahead and click OK while the emulator is
booting up I want to point out that if
you ever want to modify your emulated
devices you can click on this button
with the purple device and the Android
and open up the AVD manager to manage
your Android virtual devices it lists
out your existing devices and you can
always create another virtual device you
can select the category ur device and
then a specific device then you choose
which platform version is should be
running on and this is the only one
that's available on this computer now so
lollipop is good and we choose the
Google API is target because it will
include some Google services already
pre-installed on the emulator you can
choose next there's a couple more
options and settings that you can modify
for example if you want an SD card or a
camera you can change those here and
then you can go ahead and click finish
and it will create a new AVD for you